Speaker 1: And while we're on the subject of
things Trump has done, we obviously have to talk
about all of the investigations against him,
because recently Michael Cohen, Donald Trump's
former lawyer slash fixer, came out in an
interview and suggested that there is going to
be, quote, so much flipping. On Donald Trump
once all of these investigations get to that
point. And of course, the big one recently,
last week, Allen WEISSELBERG Trump
Organization chief financial officer,
pleaded guilty to 15 different counts. Every
count, by the way, that he was charged with, he
pleaded guilty to. They didn't drop any of them.
So he had to plead to each and every one of them.
And he's only going to get five months on
Riker's Island. He is eligible for early
release after 100 days. So he's going to
spend a little over three months in there.
But the judge did warn him last week, if you do
not cooperate fully, truthfully and honestly,
I can put you away for 10 to
15 years on Rikers, which,
given your age, is pretty much a life sentence.
And here's the best part about Weisselberg's.
Cooperation. With the prosecutors. He can't plead
the Fifth. He cannot plead the Fifth Amendment
because he's already pleaded guilty to all of
the crimes he was accused of. A plea of guilty
basically does away with your Fifth Amendment
rights of self-incrimination because you've
already admitted you did the things kind of like
the acceptance of a presidential pardon. If you
accept a presidential pardon. Our Supreme Court
says you can no longer plead the Fifth because
acceptance of a pardon is an acceptance of guilt.
So Weisselberg literally has no choice. All right.
You either go to Riker's Island for 15 years,
which probably would be the rest of his life.
Or you give us every single thing on Donald Trump.
You can't get out of it. You can't excuse it. You
can't, you know, call in sick. You can't plead the
Fifth. You can do nothing to stop what's coming.
And of course, that was just one of the examples,
of course, that Michael Cohen recently gave.
Because that's just one of the many
investigations that Donald Trump is facing.
We also have the situation in Georgia,
the Fulton County special grand jury,
and a lot of Donald Trump's friends,
including his former lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
have had to testify now. And while we do not know
what Rudy Giuliani specifically told that special
grand jury, we do know that Giuliani is out there
in the media, still defending Donald Trump, still
denying all wrongdoing, actually said recently
that he should get his law license back because he
hasn't incited a riot in the last year and a half.
But Rudy Giuliani is kind of the same situation.
Guy is 78 years old. A prison sentence for
him, especially given his recent health.
Is likely a life sentence. Even, you know,
five years. With your health conditions,
you're probably not walking out of that jail ever
again. So Giuliani, much like Weisselberg, has the
incentive to flip on Donald Trump. But with Rudy,
I think it's a different story, right? I don't
know that Rudy would flip. I still don't because
I still think Rudy Giuliani holds out a slight
amount of hope that Trump's going to get back in
office. And then what make him attorney general?
I guess he's going to do something great for me.
I just know it. I just know it. He hasn't paid the
bills that I've submitted to him, but he's totally
going to take care of me eventually, right? Yeah.
You keep on hoping. Rudy will hope right there
with you. Right. You'll get a good job in the
second Trump administration if it ever
materializes. But I'm not going to hold my breath.
If you want out of this mess, this mess, which, by
the way, all of Rudy Giuliani's legal troubles are
because he stuck his neck out for Donald Trump,
if you want out of that. You're going to have
to flip. That's your only option. And that's
basically what Michael Cohen is telling us.
All these people, whether it's with the fake
elector scheme, whether it's with the New York
investigation, whether it's with the other
New York investigation, whether it's with
the January six investigations, whether it's with
the documents investigation down at Mar a Lago,
all of these horrible things that Trump has been
implicated in with all of these walls closing in.
Somebody somewhere somehow is going to flip
on this guy. And once that first domino falls,
the rest of them, as Michael Cohen says.
Going to start flipping like crazy.